[Music]
two to eight out of ten on gamespot I
have a few broader questions I do have
some things I want to get into but first
Kali Plaga you gave it an 8 out of 10 I
think everybody here except for me has
played it in some capacity
but what is uh was the deal with this
game why'd you give it an 8 out of 10 um
well so I don't know did you play the
first one at all
no no yeah so the the first Platoon I
played of course like playing on a wii u
was so cumbersome because i had like
that was the only game i really played
after a while so number one like having
it on switch I've been saying this about
pretty much every switch game but like I
really do think that good hardware makes
a difference and that does help my
enjoyment but the main thing is like
this this game makes a lot of small
tweaks to the splatoon formula that go a
long way so single player is improved
that's probably one of like the biggest
changes as you can now use like every
weapon every weapon but in the first
game like you only had access to one
weapon in single-player and it was kind
of like okay well what's the point this
doesn't really introduced me to many of
the types of weapons I can use versus in
the single-player they make really good
use of you know the full catalog of
weapons
it's you know smart fun platforming
challenges we talked last time when we
talked about splatoon about like rail
grinding is really cool
one of the things that disappointed me
is some of those cool like platforming
and movement challenges present in the
single-player they just don't make it
into multiplayer I hold out hope that
because they Nintendo has said that they
will be releasing like free updates for
splatoon which they did for the first
game as well I'm holding out hope that
maybe they'll they'll you know add
something that makes good use of some of
the coolest parts of single-player but
you know even even without that the
multiplayer is still super fun I think
turf war is a really unique really just
you know interesting and kind of quirky
take on a shooter mode and you know
you're just basically inking the ground
and and then you know taking it let's
see you can't win based on like which
team covered more than that yeah you
don't win based on kills I mean you are
splatting opponents but you're you're
trying to ink turf and I think that's
really cool UK allows you to be
successful on a run a constant basis
everything you're doing is contributing
like is a benefit to your team mm-hmm
like you don't have to kill someone for
that to be a thing and like it happens
every five minutes and you're like
finally I contribute it it's like yeah
every single little thing you do makes a
difference yeah and that's one of the
the best parts is you know turf war
battles are three minutes long they're
really quick you get in and out of
battle really quick you're not spent
you're not spending a lot of time
waiting in lobbies although during the
review you were because there were so
few people playing but um you know it's
quick in and out and you're even a
defeat you don't feel totally like like
I never wanted to rage quit because I
kept losing because you are getting
rewards you are contributing and the
pretty much a lot of the time like if
you're playing with a bunch of randoms
who don't really know what they're doing
that was frustrating yeah because it's
like okay why are you inking over the
same things I already inked go a
different way please but for the most
part like it's consistently rewarding
you go out with the money you earn even
if you lose you get some reward
experience and in cash and you can go
buy new gear and so that constant like
feedback loop is something that I think
works really well it doesn't feel
repetitive because every every match is
different mm-hmm there's just a lot to
like about it it's a very simple concept
but I think with everything combined
like is you know do I prefer going for
you know look being aggro do I prefer
getting into combat or do I prefer
inking like there's always something to
do and you can kind of shift your
strategy based on your team so I think
there's a lot to like I will say that
multiplayer still has some logistical
the hiccups for me you can't change your
loadout in turf war which is like that's
the it's such a small it sounds like
such a small complaint but that
frustrates me to no end because if
you're are all Chargers which is like
the sniper in splatoon you're done
you're gonna lose like that's not a good
weapon for inking you're gonna get melee
to death and it's gonna suck you have no
way to see what your team is carrying
you pick one at the beginning and you're
stuck with it you pick one before
entering the lobby so you you can before
enter if you and this was frustrating
especially during the review because you
know the only people playing right now
our reviewers and treehouse people you
have your team and you want to change
your weapon you're gonna lose all those
people and yeah and if I have if I want
to change my weapon like my chances of
getting into a game when there's so few
people playing that was really low but
also I mean that's going that's going to
be mitigated once people are playing the
game but um that was frustrating and
it's also just like if you're stuck with
bad team comp you're you're done like it
is it doesn't seem to be a reason for it
yeah there's like no reason you can't
just like an all over site uh you could
in the splatfest so that's another thing
where I hope that's an update that they
roll out I mean like if I I don't know
it's just like weird Nintendo decisions
where it's like you know why are you
doing this why are you making
multiplayer harder than it has to be why
can't I why do I have to use an app that
can only be let's talk about that little
voice chat yeah people and people were
tweeting at me like I don't see why
that's a problem I I think no voice chat
is a positive it's like yeah 2017 this
is watching in the app is only only
available if the app is open and your
phone is unlocked which is ridiculous to
me because a change of phone settings if
you want to get us out II know that's
gonna drain the heck out of your battery
right you can't like if you want to
switch over to you know text um but do
you like come join our game nope you
can't do that you'll lose your chat if
you want to you look up a walkthrough
you can't do that either
calls you or yeah if your mom is like
are you alive you're like yes there's
there's no way to justify or make this
like seem like it's reasonable and in
ten days part you know it's it's very
bad it's in elegant they screwed up yeah
there's no ippolit you can't make any
apologies for it it really it's like you
can't even say oh but there's a Sloot it
doesn't matter there's it's it's the
most ridiculous cumbersome workaround
that I could have imagined because like
you also can't get game audio through
the app so you have to get a special
dongle that connects to both your
controller and your phone so you can get
both which is like why would I do that
the other workaround just high volume on
your TV yeah
your friends get the feedback or what so
it's just that's frustrating
couple that with the fact that like now
the new iPhone doesn't have a headphone
jack charge and the some arguments in
favor of not having like readily
available voice chat we're like Oh a
Nintendo wants everyone to have the same
experience but this is a multiplayer
team focused game and I can't organize
team comp especially in ranked yeah so
this is ridiculous this weird dongle if
you need an infographic to show us how
to do something that every game just
allows you to do with yeah and also
other thing is the switch has parental
controls so if you're a parent and you
don't want your kid to you know like
here you know the f-word you can just do
that in the you don't have to make it so
like voice chat isn't available for
everyone just because a kid might hear
some stuff they shouldn't hear like the
parental controls are already there you
know what your kids are probably playing
call duty you're at their friend's house
yeah you're in the [ __ ] anyway probably
watching porn at their friend's yeah how
old are we talking no anyway damn dingo
and the twitch had mentioned yeah he was
asking is the chat any good doesn't
sound like it is is that well okay we'll
say I downloaded the app and the actual
like splatoon info is pretty cool
like I was able to see like all my stats
and like my last 50 games and like which
ones I won and with which weapons were
like hanyan app yeah so that part was
cool but the voice chat part I'm like
not down with but it does remind me of
the Destiny app and that I just kind of
want to look at it when I'm not playing
like look at so colorful and cute look
at my gear so I there's a use for it I
guess you can also see which maps are in
rotation which is nice if you like
really hate a map you're like I'm
thinking about playing right now and
you're like I really don't want to play
on not that I don't think there's any
maps like that in this game but
reference I do know and you would know a
Callie like as far as the I guess you'd
call a quick chat on the left side of
controller right you can be like I
follow me there's like there's only two
there's Booya there's our
which is very useful Booya those were
more emotes than like me occasion yeah
well there is like a this way right this
way is a couple but I even that it's
like I don't even know which way you are
42 I don't looking at what you're doing
and so yeah it to the point of like you
know you look at rocket League which has
a phenomenal quick chat system I think
so no it does I was thinking about what
I do with Oh what we do yeah so what I'm
trying to say is that for something like
turf war right we're like one of the
problems is when I was playing I feel
like we would be up against for people
who like were amazing I knew what the
hell and they talking communicating the
problem I was thinking it was like when
I had that team and you know you're
interfering you're trying to cover your
side of the map and then one of their
guys comes around and starts like
wrecking your side that you were a
painted the only two commands I feel
like that would be used for like I'm
attacking or like I'm defending or some
form of that we're like hey I'm just
gonna roll back literally with the
roller and just manage our side like
that's it that's there's your roll cool
that guy's doing that like I don't know
like the tactics I mean it just seemed
so frustrating when I someone was
playing I like it took me a while to
understand how to how to like get into
it early what I should be doing yeah
what what your role is I mean like I was
playing in we I mean around here we had
four codes so we would play in the same
room and I would just shout out things
like like it's unlike we were playing a
MOBA I was like I'm going mid or
whatever it is some of the maps are like
lay bebe's based not like in the way
that you know Call of Duty has moved to
Lane base but like there are you can
kind of go in different because I'm just
stretches stretches are like a vertical
you know you can go on a different level
than somebody else and kind of double
your effectiveness so I think like
discord is a much better solution than
yeah like it's the frustrating thing
though is in splatoon at least with turf
war if you join your friends lobby you
aren't guaranteed to be on the same team
so I like I would do this it's the same
as splatoon one like I'd be in a skype
chat with people and then like three of
them would be on the other team and
they'd be like Kali mute us
you still can't like squat up you can in
League battles so this is this is they
did try to fix it for some modes and I
do appreciate that there's like a casual
mode that's like jump in jump out that's
not a lot of pressure it's about like
having fun and you still want to win but
you get rewards for losing so that's
fine
there's ranked battle which is returning
but it has 3 modes ones like a capture
the flag labor first capture the flag
ones like almost like overwatch like
you're escorting a tower to a point
what is reverse capture the flag exactly
have you played like it's like assault
in Halo where like you're bringing a
bomb to so rather than like rescuing a
flag from their base you don't ringing
one thing but it's like a bomb yeah I
was on the exact same wavelength as you
with that I've been watching halo stuff
I was weird yes sorry but yeah though
that's cool on the same wavelength and
then there's one that's um
oh you're controlling zones kind of like
ecologies dominations you're controlling
by inking a certain area and then you're
trying to get all three or however many
there are and you have to hold them for
a certain amount of time and then the
game's over and you guys win in order to
unlock League battle you have to be
ranked be- or above in ranked battle in
any mode to get to rank values to be
level 10 and turf war multiplayer like
you have to play to her floor first then
you get you reach level 10 you unlock
rank then you get B - you unlock the
League League is the new one where you
can party up with one or three other
friends that's in groups of two or four
and that one you are on their team and
you can be in chat but it's just it's
it's it's who - its - yeah okay I don't
want to be hyperbolic but that sounds
like a nightmare to figure it out I mean
12-year old me would be like screw this
like is that is that meant to basically
mix up those those early like matches
where you have those like you know heavy
experience players on one team
just like wrecking job if that's gonna
mean spit balling you're like is there
is that like for that I'm sure there is
a Nintendo style justification for it I
wish that turf war I could play turf war
with you know in league battle but
League battle using ranked battle modes
so like turf war is always casual you
can't be like I'm super good at turf war
and I want to party up with my friends
and there's just I mean I feel like
we're being super negative I did give it
an 8 I think it's really fun I it's the
kind of game as a shooter fan that like
kid me would have gone crazy for and
that current me is also super obsessed
with and I can't wait to play when more
people are online and because right now
you get can't get a match because all
the reviewers did their reviews and now
they're not playing because it's like
there's like six of us but I mean yeah
it's just I hope that they patched some
of these multiplayer things out or
figured out I don't know if Nintendo
will because they're notoriously bad
with online it's just frustrating when
it's like okay this is a team based
online
focus multiplayer game yeah why is this
difficult for you yeah to clarify we're
not like against using discord or Skype
chat which are both viable options you
seems weird that they wouldn't include
it in the game because I mean even like
if I was if I just had a switch and I
was like like stuck to Nintendo stuff I
don't think I'd be too familiar with
discord if I wasn't like a PC gamer but
of course you can download skype easily
and we're not and I'm completely
advocating doing that if it's gonna help
you play this game but you're doing you
could just do a group phone call on your
iPhone yeah like whatever there's so
many ways to get around at the point be
even have to figure that out point being
is that this problem was solved probably
at least a decade ago consoles and here
it is Nintendo with their fancy schmancy
look at our cool system it's so
different and unique but it's missing
this really basic thing that you guys
are all used to that is classic Nintendo
that is almost essential to like a
higher level performance in this type of
game right like even if I go in with
like I said team comp is a really big
problem
that's probably the biggest problem
aside from voice chat I know not
everybody cares my voice chat the team
comp thing is a glaring issue or you
cannot see what people are carrying into
battle you can end up with everybody has
the same weapon and y'all are screwed
there was one thing I really liked
playing the weapons were like way more
in-depth than like I ever imagined we're
like in the single-player I was like oh
this charge kind of sniper rifle was
like my go-to I mean my first like few
hours soon player like this
like ring my own lanes said etc and then
into the multiplayer like I was like
this gun sucks against people and I
cannot shoot anyone looks like a high
skill ceiling yeah it's a pretty long
charge and obviously like it's really
precise as far as aiming however what
was really interesting was was I avoided
that and I saw and one of the enemy guys
like about five matches later he's just
in the middle of the map and he said
there and he's just creating lanes for
his team but he's like not moving so you
just kind of like you see when Christ
day is like all these weapons like I see
someone using it or applying it every
way I'm like oh damn like that's how you
use that gun
you're just a team player it was like
really cool to to just yeah I mean again
like you know each weapon has like so
many different applications yeah yeah
like I said I feel like we sound very
negative I do say a lot of positive
things in my review that's one of them
is like they made these really small
tweaks to weapons that like I'm still
figuring out the best way to use it the
the charger you can which is actually
pretty popular in multiplayer if I
remember correctly it is a difficult
weapon to use but like the fact that you
know somebody can be really useful
creating lanes because you know going
through the ink is how you reload so
somebody who's like like who needs to go
to the front lines or whatever or who's
on offense like needs the charger to set
that up for them like that's really
smart or on it works really well on
certain maps like more eight hours it's
like that there's all right a lot of
verticality on that map having a sniper
is really good they also made it so you
can hold the charge in ink which makes
you more sneaky and I just made a lot of
song changes and as a returning splatoon
player when you see that stuff it feels
like this isn't just it's not a reskin
right it's been redeveloped in some ways
yeah they like really really weighted
weapon it seems like balance and you
know how you use each weapon to Inc
versus do damage it's you know there's
like new weapons like the Dooleys which
is the first weapon to add movement a
unique movement so you can do a dodge
roll which is which is cool because
you're you're more mobile while not in
ink which is the biggest or even in
you're in
yep did you think otherwise you're
you're screwed low as molasses yeah they
also added new abilities to gear which
is really cool because you know as a
returning player I'm like oh that I'm
gonna figure out a new combination that
works for my new play style with this
weapon that's been changed and so
there's a lot to dig into if you're
returning but it's not you know a total
overhaul and it's this it's still the
fun like already good game that it was
if you had if you didn't play on Wii U I
would highly recommend it there's just
some frustrations that's my thing uh
it's good because speaking personally
and I'm sure I'm not alone in this I
wasn't super into the Wii U I don't
think it was like a failure like a lot
of people say but obviously the switch
is doing much much better sales wise and
just reception wise I think I can jump
into splatoon with the second one right
I don't have to go back to the first one
it sounds very much like you do not I
mean the it takes place I think two
years after the first game but I mean
like the lore in splatoon is very like
hidden under the surface wank wank
overwatch I'm destiny if you yeah and
like so if you want to dig into it
that's cool
you're not you're not gonna go in being
like what's happening it's you know does
a really good job of you know getting
you right into it cool
so splatoon to eight out of ten on
GameSpot reviewed by Kelly plaguey you
can go check that out
if you want to read more in depth or
watch the video and YouTube working spot